كان هذا نهجًا كلاسيكيًا من قبل الرئيس الأمريكي
حديثًا صارمًا حقًا ضد إيران
ولكن في النهاية يوفر بعض المجال للمناورة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالنفط بشكل عام ، فهذه
العقوبات صارمة 900 كيان
مشمولة بالإجراءات الشاملة لكن الولايات المتحدة.
غيرت انتخابات التجديد النصفي
أولويات ترامب في اختياراته في محاولة
لإغلاق صادرات النفط الإيرانية إلى الصفر أو
إعطاء مهلة لتخفيف الأسعار في
مضخة الغاز لقاعدته الانتخابية عندما وصل سعر النفط إلى 86
دولارًا للبرميل في أوائل أكتوبر / تشرين الأول.
لقد أراد المزيد من النفط الخام من
أوبك واللاعبون مثل المملكة العربية السعودية
ملزمون
في نفس الوقت الذي
تنخفض فيه صادرات إيران ولكن من الواضح أننا لا نرسم
مسارًا متوقعًا لانخفاض صادرات إيران
إلى أقل من مليون برميل
يوميًا بحلول الربع الأول من العام المقبل
وحوالي 7  إلى 800000 برميل يوميًا بحلول
منتصف العام المقبل حتى الآن ، فقد مرت
على هذا المسار جنبًا إلى جنب مع عقوبات snapback التي
فرضتها الولايات المتحدة  أعلنت إعفاءات استيراد النفط
لثماني دول من
أوروبا ، وكانت إيطاليا في اليونان ، وكلتاهما تحافظان على
علاقات في مجال الطاقة مع طهران ، والصين ، والهند ،
وتركيا ، كانت جميعها ضد الإجراءات الأمريكية
، والمستوردين الآسيويين الآخرين ، اليابان
، كوريا الجنوبية وتايوان ، الإعفاءات
تمنحهم الوقت للعثور على إمدادات بديلة
غير النفط  يقول المحللون الاستراتيجيون إن
وقف صادرات النفط الإيرانية إلى الصفر حتى العام المقبل أمر غير مرجح للغاية ،
جون تيفت أرياس CNN business
Abu Dhabi